grexit it's a huge impact because we
will lose at least 50% of our fleet and
that's a disaster a real disaster but
Exodus macabre exit came as a surprise
to us and not a good surprise
I am worried it is like a monster
emerging
[Music]
my name is kudo fatima I'm a Dutch
fisherman from the island pixel and my
name is Finn Visser representing the
Dutch fishing industry I fish in British
waters 80% of the year and if I am NOT
allowed to fish there anymore I'll have
to go somewhere else but other
colleagues are already fishing in Dutch
waters so if I go there we have to share
it would be like fishing on a stamp
so this could have a domino effect a
very bad domino effect
for instance here in this option in this
fishing community if one or two or three
vessels will have to stop then there is
no break-even position economically for
the option
everything everything tumbles around
it has there have been so much fish in
the North Sea since 1957 and that's a
very very good sign and that is because
of the joint policy of the EU Member
States but the collective management is
gone what used to be our colleagues our
friends working together in European
fisheries politics and all of a sudden
it's turned upside down as if we are
strangers and that is a very very bad
feeling
our friends are no longer our friends
our special Montana cameras client humor
the hikmaíah thing as a boy I went
fishing with my father in British waters
he told me where to go catch the best
fish darah be the best arezzo part a
deep lake and dart lake and that is
follow these are my waters and I know
them like the back of my head that
connect Dara's mabrook sharks Emma
the reality after brexit is the reality
before exit and we have to come to an
agreement together so the Brits export
the fish they'll catch and they import
the fish they eat and if they want to
sell Scottish farmed salmon language
teams etc to the continent then they
should be reasonable and it's tit for
tat and it's a fair deal that we can
keep fishing in their waters as we have
done for 500 years